As can I drink baking soda water to help alkalize by cell or have had people since our clinic
mainly sees people with cancer, many people say I'm drinking high pH water,
thinking that's that's alkalizing yourself because they are holding to a very incorrect theory
that cancer can't grow in an acidic environment, which is just completely done physiological.
So cancer in itself because it's growing and it's a mass that's in a rapid replication
is created in a acidic environment where it's growing and yes it'd be great to
alkalize that environment but you don't alkalize that environment by drinking alkaline water or
drinking baking soda. Anybody that says that is just not understanding basic physiology.
These are the things that burp me about Instagram and Facebook and even natural practitioners
that are making statements that are absurd that are just physiologically absurd.
So I hate to say there's companies that sell you machines that give you high pH water.
There's people that go with a store and you buy a water that's at 9.4 pH, very alkaline.
All you're doing is alkalizing your stomach. You're completely counterattuitive,
it does not make any sense whatsoever. And you're physiologically damaging,
you're stomach, you're damaging, you're gut, you're setting yourself up for all sorts of problems,
thinking that you're doing something healthy.
I mean there's a positive of the internet is there's a lot of great stuff and you could
basically get an education without leaving your home. The negative is there's a lot of
wrong information and you could mislead yourself too. So you not understanding some basic
physiology can be a problem. There was a question asked a few weeks ago, my son or my daughter
wants to go into naturopathic medicine, natural medicine. What should I do?
What school would you push them towards? There's some naturopathic type schools that are online
that are teaching information that is just completely wrong. It's sad, it's really sad.
And then people are graduating thinking that they should do things like this. They're telling people to
drink alcohol and water or they're telling people to drink baking soda water or to test their
with pH drips, test their saliva or test their urine to see if they're alcohol or acidic. It's just
total nonsense. And it just gives natural doctors a bad name when you see this silliness that's
out there that is worse than silliness because it could hurt people. So I was kind of at a loss,
I was caught off-hand with that question because I didn't know how to point people to the right
education to take. Now there are some good online courses and online naturopathic schools
up to go to. I just I can't think of any off the top of my head.
I'll have to research out a little bit. I would suggest take our courses. I mean,
they're 50 bucks for our autoimmune course. I just edit four videos today onto that course,
onto modules three on that course. That's going to take you several months to get through that.
You know, you'll be smarter than most natural doctors by just going through that course.
I'm not trying to pop myself up. I've learned from people, I'm standing at other people's shoulders.
That's the you want to have a heart that's constantly learning that knows because the more you
really know, the more you really know how much you don't know. The more you realize what you need
to learn, somebody just text me, it's the one naturopathic school is Eden School.
Natural New Eden School for Natural Health. That's it. Thank you guys. New Eden School for Natural Health.
I'd recommend that one. That's a good one. But there's another one. Trinity. I would not recommend.
There's several online schools. I would not recommend. There's a huge benefit to going,
like going through car practice school or going through a four-year naturopathic school. That is
the you're going to learn physiology. That's what you are not going to learn through these online
schools just because they don't have that that hefty enough curriculum.
So we have had a couple of our practitioners in the past did the New Eden School and I think that's
the best one that's out there right now. But I did look at the trinity and I was just very
disappointed with that. So be careful of incorrect information. You know, if you have questions
about these things also, remember to go to our website cutters clinic.com. We have well over a thousand
blogs with a really good search engine. You can go to that search thing and put in any question you
want. Pretty good chance that I've been video or did a talk about it or wrote an article about
it if I did it. Ask the question out here. So go to our holistichealthour.com website and ask a question.